James Lipton I'm the creator and
executive producer writer and host of
Inside the Actors Studio and the
founding dean of the Actors Studio drama
school of Pace University
Stella was I think in all the
disciplines that I studied in my life a
formal disciplines performance
disciplines she was the best teacher I
ever had of anything better than any of
my university teachers better than any
of the teachers I had worked with in the
study of in liberal arts study in the
study of the law
she was quite simply the most gifted
teacher I ever met
she was aspiring it was eccentric
sometimes she was quite nutty but at the
core of it was this steely technique
which she had acquired over many years
and which he had acquired in fact from
San Slav scheme self now Estella was
there were two streams of the
Stanislavski system essentially that
came out of the group theatre the two
streams exists today they run parallel
to each other and in the end they often
cross and reach the same result Stella
was trained at the group theatre
principally by Lee Strasberg
was its teacher and director Harold
Clurman was also running the group
theater as was Gerald Crawford in I
think 1934 she went to Paris and
discovered that Stanislavski was there
for the summer and she confronted him
and said that his system which she had
been studying scrupulously since these
members of the group theater had
encountered the Moscow Art Theatre when
it came to New York in the 1920s was
driving her crazy and Stanislavski
listened to her complaints and and
agreed to teach her which he did I think
for something like a month or six weeks
he trained her in a role and then she
came back to New York and she there were
all of her colleagues at the group
theater this was a group of course that
had changed everything in America the
group theater had brought the
Stanislavski system into
America and they had changed the way
actors act the way writers write the way
directors direct and they were becoming
a dominant force the dominant force the
theatre and ultimately in film and they
were waiting for and they said well what
did the master have to say and she said
he's abandoned emotional memory now that
may be meaningless to anybody listening
to this but to an actor it has some
meaning emotional memory was what was
been skaia taught when she remained
behind from the from the Moscow Art
Theatre and and Strasbourg and others
were very influenced by it it is what
people sometimes think of as the Santa
zovsky system in which one recalls one's
own experiences that are similar to
maybe even identical to the experiences
of the character and brings back from
the core of one's being the experience
it isn't really what people think it is
it is more complex and more interesting
than I have described it because it
isn't just in banishing from the world
and remembering when the dog died and
then opening one's eyes with tears it's
much more interesting and complicated
than that and it involves recalling
occurrences in one's life which evoked
emotions similar to the characters
emotions and and then one reviews them
but not in the way the public might
think simply remembering what was the
what was the time of day was at night
was a day was the was it outside visit
insight was inside do you remember the
room was the room warm cold can you see
the wallpaper or the paint etc refining
and defining and recalling in the most
intimate detail the experience not not
necessarily allowed but in one's own
recollection usually under the guidance
of the director and what happens is that
you you when you read
a certain point in that exercise of
effective memory emotional memory you
begin you begin to relive it so vividly
that whatever emotions you had at the
time come flooding back now Stella
argued that this took her away from the
play away from the character away from
what was happening the place she felt
that it was an impediment many people
would disagree with her there is still
actors who use emotional memory
affective memory which was the
Strasbourg's emphasis though not his
total emphasis he taught everything at
the Actors Studio but nevertheless she
felt that that it impeded her and he
said I don't use it anymore
Stanislavski said for that very reason
and instead I'm interested in what the
character wants at any given moment in
the given circumstances you must be
rooted in the play do not depart from
the play don't cut yourself off from
your partner in the scene or your
partners don't don't go so deep in
yourself that you no longer exist for
your partner and for the character and
for the play you must since said
Stanislavski and said Stella you must be
so thoroughly immersed in the given
circumstances of the play then you
decide what it is at any given moment
that the actor wants and when you try to
achieve what that actor wants as
ardently as the character and what that
character wants I should say as when you
try to achieve it the emotions will come
just in the act of trying to if I'm
trying to convince you that you must
never ever ever speak to this person
again I'm going to try to persuade you
that's my action I'm going to persuade
you've never talked to the sir look how
already I'm more animated and if you if
it if it recall it requires an even more
powerful action the animation is going
to be complete when Mark Riedel the
great director of on Golden Pond other
films a member of the actors
to do a student of Stanford Meisner he
was sent for my students I recall yes
and and he on our stage of inside the
Actor's Studio
he demonstrated for our students who are
masters to be candidates after all he
said look I can demonstrate this very
easily for you I'm gonna take you and
put you in a closet I'm gonna lock that
door from the outside and I will say to
you your action is to get out of the
closet and I mean get out of that closet
you have 60 seconds he said well you're
going to begin to struggle to get out of
that closet but the locked door is the
obstacle to the action which a great
playwright writes into every scene and
he said after 30 seconds you're going to
be emotional by the time I release the
door you're gonna be hysterical why did
you go did you try to remember some
moment in your life when you were this
emotional no you weren't thinking about
that at all all you were thinking about
was getting out of that damn closet that
was Stella's emphasis I'm not saying
that either side is correct as a matter
of fact I think the best possible
technique unites the two because there
are moments when one has problems with
with with actually accessing the deep
and difficult emotions of of oneself and
an exercise an emotional memory or an
affective memory exercise can release it
can have a wonderful effect but for the
most part I think Stella emphasized you
can if you know what you want Alan Alda
on our stage would studied this
technique said there should be a summing
over the entrance to every stage as the
actor is about to go on stage it says
what do you want and that is its it gets
more complicated than that is divided
into beats in a moment to moment
decisions about what the character wants
into the into an overall action
that takes you through the whole play
but generally speaking this is what
Stella taught and there are exercises
that teach you to do it it's not easy it
sounds much simpler than it is when the
two sides divided so to speak now
they've come together again but from
four decades there was on the one side
Strasbourg and his disciples who
emphasized emotional memory and but not
exclusively he's been maligned in that
way and Stella on the other Stella Adler
Harold Clurman Robert Lewis Sanford
Meisner these these were the great
exponents of the later work of
stanislavski's life the action the
objective the super objective which is
that overall action that takes you
through the play and and the devotion to
given circumstances both sighs emphasize
concentration you have to concentrate in
a way that normal people don't when our
students come to the actress to do drama
school at Pace University I was Dean for
10 years I was the founding dean I am no
longer I'm dean emeritus now but I
always speak to them when they come into
the school and I say to them look with
the work that you're going to do here
you are because these emotional memory
exercises they're also called sense
memory sense memory they are the memory
of five senses of our five senses that's
all we have and it will make you
extremely sensitive you're about to
separate yourself from the rest of the
world there will come a point in your
education at our school but any good
school where you achieve what's called
breakthrough but for the first time you
cross the barrier and it's the Rubicon
you can never go back again and you now
you sense more than other people do you
will see more hear more feel more etc
than other people do and
you will be sensitive to what to the
moment to your partner to your action to
your partner's action which may conflict
with yours to the play in a way in which
other people are not and and then I
would add to that the fact that all of
these great teachers Strasbourg Stella
Meisner Louis Clement all of them they
emphasize listening now you're listening
to me right when you speak to me I'm
listening to you
in life we listen to other people listen
with with varying degrees of
concentration and attention right
actress must learn to listen in a
different way Alan Alda who really
understands these things very well I
think on our stage at Inside the Actors
Studio said the the way to understand
listening the act and art of listening
is the following if what you hear
changes you in any way listen if it
doesn't really all listen we listen all
the time in our lives where we're
listening to television we're listening
to our mates at dinner we're listening
to the traffic in the street we listen
but this is a different kind of a this
is a listening that is so there is so
acute that is so focused and
concentrated that if the other person
the other actor says I have some very
bad news for you your mother has died it
really hits it's not a stage it's not
makeup it's not it's not scenery in
costumes somebody has just told you that
you the character that the character's
mother has died and and it doesn't have
to be that big it can be a small thing
but
you are listening I often ask our guests
we've had 250 of them in 16 years I've
Inside the Actors Studio a hand of our
school what's the single most important
thing that you would tell an actor
listen this but it's that particular
kind of listening of which an actor
becomes capable in time doesn't happen
in a day that and patience and as Paul
Newman said when he was the first guest
I've Inside the Actors Studio 16 years
ago and someone said give me one word
Paul said persistence persistence and
then he told a lie he said I was born an
ordinary actor I will die an ordinary
actor but I've persisted yes that was
the lie not that he persisted but the
newest ordinaire was anything but
I must go
fess that when I'm alone in my study
here in the art writing that's what I'm
happy really that's when I'm
unequivocally happy I may be writing
well and maybe writing poorly but I
enjoy the act of writing and and
sometimes when it turns out okay
I feel any Latian that is incomparable
a good day's writing when I turn off my
computer after I know that I've written
okay or as well as I can write that's a
day well spent the people questionnaire
that I asked other people when I have an
occasion on a rare occasion answered in
the answer to the question what turns
you on is words not mine
other people's words words words that's
what turns me on
so I would say that that writing both
the act of writing and of course of
reading other people's work is for me
the supreme joy always accepting the the
greatest joy of all which is the time I
get to spend with my wife
I cornered the market on the most
peculiar habit of the English language
namely the designation of groups of
things by a term we all know a few a
gaggle of geese a pride of lions a host
of angels and and we use them without
thinking about them a chorus of
complaint and I was one day I suddenly
thought to myself why a gaggle of geese
why a pride of lions a pride of lions
pride really it's the quintessence of a
lion he's proud who said that we will
capture the entire quintessence of this
beast in a single word pride lies and
that started me on a search that lasted
for years and took me finally to the the
bowels of the main reading room of the
British Museum where I was actually in
possession at last of the original books
of hunting in which these terms were
compiled principally the book of st.
Albans this is 15th century stuff and I
discovered it was a charm of finches
properly when the only profession a
gentleman could ever admit to was
hunting so he had to know the proper
terms he saw charm of finches and
unkindness of Ravens of Parliament of
owls an exaltation of larks a leap of
leopards these are beautiful terms an
ostentatious of peacocks I was fastened
there they were these lists that were
compiled in the 15th century and some of
the first books ever printed in England
there was that important and then I
discovered a Pontifical 'ti of prophets
a superfluity of nuns and I thought my
god
they were playing word games with them
in the 15th century and I finally
compiled all of the original terms with
their provenances that took a lot of
digging because most of them are in
Middle English so I had to translate on
the Middle English into modern English
and I fell in love with them and I began
to invite my own an acre of dentists in
in the 15th century they said a rascal
of boys so I said an acne of adolescence
a lurch of buses a slouch of models an
unction of undertakers in a larger group
an extreme unction of Undertaker's and I
couldn't stop it was like eating peanuts
and I wrote this big book which became
the definitive book on this subject and
ultimately in all of the introductions
that I wrote to the various sections of
it became a love letter to this
magnificent English language it's been
used as a textbook in countless schools
it's been published all over the world
and you'll have to forgive me for
bragging you can discount 50% of this
because I'm saying it but all the same
it is my letter to the world and and if
people would ask me it was a one book
that you've written that means the most
you clearly it's an exaltation of Lorex
there was in the in Shakespeare's time
also a collective term they were called
a cry of players
isn't that pretty a cry of players I
decided that in my time it would be a
queue of actors queu II a line a queue
of actors that's my term for it
though I think a cryo player is probably
a lot better
with great care that happened also by
happenstance in 1994 I had by then at
the urging of Norman Mailer and his wife
Norris Church and others I had gone over
to the Actors Studio to see what they
were doing I'd been trained by Stella it
was a different world but I went over
there and they Norman said you've gotta
come we're doing good work we're doing
interesting work I went over to saw what
they were doing and I liked it a lot and
I became involved in the studio number
work I began to work there and
ultimately I became a member and very
deeply involved in the work of the
studio by this time Strasburg had long
since passed away I never got to meet
him I regret to say and I was so
involved in the work that I eventually
became a member of the board of the
actress to you and just before it became
remember the board I became aware as we
all did that in those parlous times 1994
for cultural institutions the studio
which had never been a school never
charged tuition which had never been a
club the charged membership fees that
had been living from hand to mouth since
1947 that like every other cultural
institution it was it was impoverished
and one night after we'd been discussing
it and how the studio could possibly
survive under these circumstances I woke
up the next morning and I had an idea it
was crystal clear in detail it was to
create a school for the first time a
degree granting school in a university
under the aegis of the Actors Studio
we created the program the actors to do
drama school and in this in the fall of
1994 we opened our doors to the public
and within three years who had largest
Graduate Drama School in America and
today of course we're at Pace University
were bigger and better than ever so in
1994 September we opened our doors we
were accredited master's degree program
three year MFA and I said to myself I
don't know what they had said B by the
way because this was your idea Jim you
led the group that created the
curriculum others participated Ellen
Burstyn and Blanco and Lee grant and
Carolyn Lynn Norman Mailer Paul Newman
and they said look you this is your idea
you can't walk away from it now you've
got started I said I'm finishing them
welcome lyrics to my third musical I
said you've got to at least get it
started I said okay I'll do it for a
year I did it for 10 years it became its
founding dean because I felt so in love
with it but I was now I had this this
master's degree program and I had people
who teach for all year long I had people
who would come to a six-week workshop
and then I thought well I've got to
attract to us our colleagues members of
the studio colleagues that we've worked
with outside the studio in films theatre
I've got to bring in there for one night
they can only give me one night of their
lives okay I wrote a letter give me one
night of your life teach our students
and I'll conduct this seminar and I got
a response from Paul Newman guys hopper
like Baldwin Sally Fields and I
I sent a letter back into the
professional community from which I had
come saying that these people are liable
to say something that's worth preserving
that means television cameras we can't
afford them anybody interested and Bravo
the Bravo network which was then very
small took this existential leap with us
and so it began anyway there ever were
and I had this school now and we had
this I had this Monday evenings I did
this seminar and there were television
cameras I made two fateful decisions one
were a school we will always be a school
this will always be a class therefore
we're not interested in gross we're not
interested in gossip
we're interested in craft it will be
about craft which is not exactly a
goldmine in television and nevertheless
it will be about craft and second there
will be no pre-interview I'd been on all
the television programs as an actor as a
writer as a director as a producer I've
been on everybody else's show and there
was always a pre-interview somebody
would come with a tape recorder and
you'd talk for 3-4 hours they take it
back it would be transcribed and they'll
be given to the writers as many writers
you see on although shows Larry King
Letterman Leno etc and then they choose
the answers that will be most evocative
on their show and then they write the
questions that will evoke them and they
give them to the host
well they do five shows in a week so
they have to do it that way I couldn't
do it they're much smarter than I am
much cleverer but no I said I'm gonna
there's me no Prine of you what did that
mean I had to do the homework no one
else it takes me two weeks to prepare
for each guest I work seven days a week
and I work about twelve hours a day from
the beginning of September until the end
of May
here I take two days off Christmas and
New Year's thanksgiving sometimes
sometimes two and a half and the result
is that I bonded myself to my desk I
grappled myself to it with hoops of
Steel to quote the bard and I I do that
homework myself I have a massive raw
material which is provided to me by a
graduate high school Jeremy Carrick and
it just gives me everything that exists
on this particular person and then I
have two weeks in which to shape it and
turn it into a narrative which is what
our show is intended to be at the
beginning a middle and an end with
themes that re occurring recur and and
then I put them on in my on with
PowerPoint in my computer I put on blue
cards with questions that will evoke the
answers hopefully that I have found in
their personal and professional
histories and there are about four or
five hundred of those cards for each
person you asked about my preparation
that's my preparation and it all began
with the decision that there would be no
pre-interview the guest and I have
talked about it often it's as if it were
a circus tent with a rope ladder he on
one end rope ladder on the other huh I
go up one rope ladder the guest goes up
the other and we meet on a high wire
with no net for four to five hours
that's how long they're with me on our
stage because it's a class I edited
ultimately to an hour occasionally for
two hours for two hour special but that
that that's we're up there and there's
no net because the guest doesn't know
what's coming next
and I have no guarantee that they'll
give me the answer that I think I'm
gonna find from the research I've done
if it's on my card
this is not going to come as a surprise
concentration
when you're taking a plane off the
ground from the moment those wheels
leave the ground your pee icy
pilot-in-command
anybody else sitting in that airplane
you're in charge you got to get them
back they're landing an airplane in I
think is the most difficult thing that I
ever learned to feel in my life
most people agree that's why so many
people never finish their training they
just can't do it
and and you're the wonderful thing about
it is that when you're as I say you're
coming in for landing and you're in a
busy environment there are other
airplanes there they're talking a lot of
the control tower is talking to you
they're talking to you fast they're
talking to you in this pilot speak which
is cursory and mysterious until you
learn all these things are happening at
once and the grounds coming up at you
and you're moving in at 125 miles an
hour so it's happening fast right and
the result is that you can't think about
anything else it erases the rest of the
world which is a wonderful reason to go
flying and it is the same as in acting
in that respect it's total concentration
until you see that center line going
right between your legs dividing your
body in half you have the squeak of the
wheels you make a nice nice soft landing
and roll out concentration my favorite
sport demands the same thing of me I
realized it long since that this is why
both of these things appeal to me
because they forced me to focus on them
and not on anything else that I have
brought with me from my life from the
world no worries no aspirations no ideas
no plans no nothing
you just focus and that is I became a
show jumper I show my jump horses over
big dangerous fences in competition and
got very very good at it
and quite a high level and I realized
long since that yeah it's the same thing
that appeals to me about it you can't
think about anything else
in either case jumping horses over
fences in competition show jumping
we're flying an airplane for whatever
purpose you are you're the pea I see and
the alternative to doing it correctly is
death or injury I've been injured badly
on horses I finally stopped seven years
ago when I had a very bad injury and had
to be helicoptered into New York but I
miss it I miss it till the day I died
and I'm convinced to this day that I
could get on a horse and jump of course
offences satisfactorily it doesn't leave
you I've described myself as a
recovering equestrian taking it one day
at a time these are two things that I
love very very much and I realized I
loved them for the same reason why
because they involve risk
well I've played Hamlet when I was
student with Robert Lewis he assigned me
Hamlet and I would say I and Mildred
dunnock who was the original wife in
Death of a Salesman was also stood in
that class and she agreed to play my
mother Gertrude so I would pick a scene
I won't dare to recite and even now but
it would be the heiress scene on the
scene with his mother look here upon
this portrait and on this that whole
scene because it's so exquisitely
written so perfectly risen written the
emotions are so accessible in the
character is so clear I would say that
scene the entire scene